there is a tragic and uh unmovable love
between those two characters i had fun
with her this season because she was
stripped of something which defines her
what has defined her up until now i
think it's a really really cool way to
view their relationship that doesn't go
straight into a sort of a love triangle
trope
you recently came out and said that
you've always believed that jennifer and
geralt are meant to be i know that a lot
of fans also ship tris
after season two do you still stand by
your ship choice i'm a big believer in
the source material and and there is a a
tragic and uh unmovable love between
those two characters and so uh that's
that's something which is important to
me and again as faithful as we can be to
the source material that's the most
important thing
my dream
of becoming important to someone
you're important to me
the witcher fans are very divided on
team jennifer versus team tris
and i've got to say i'm a jennifer fan
can you talk to me a little bit about
that and navigating the love triangle
traps of this world
absolutely so it's funny because when i
first um
started reading witcher and thinking
about the witcher people had spoken to
me about the yantriss geralt triangle
which really isn't in the books that
much that's a real video game story in
the books though there is a very sort of
special relationship between trace and
geralt and trust definitely has more
intimate feelings but one of the things
that henry and i talked about talked
about from the very beginning is that
geralt thinks jennifer is dead
he is still mourning her he is not ready
to move on and then we started talking
about how that would impact triss's
journey as well because what we didn't
want is a woman who's just constantly
lusting after a man that she can't have
and not um growing or learning or
changing and one of the things that we
landed on was that her
feelings for geralt are less about
geralt himself and more about coming out
of the sort of trauma that she
experienced from season one so learning
to feel again and it's one of my most
favorite sort of speeches from the from
the episode which is when she said like
i just needed to know that i could feel
again and thank you for being there with
me in that i think it's a really really
cool way to view their relationship that
doesn't go straight into a sort of a
love triangle trip
welcome back
anya i've got to give you major props
because you took yedifer to a place that
we have never seen before someone who is
completely powerless but still finding
her power within what was your mindset
in approaching her in season two i never
really know until the day
i like to kind of discover everything in
the moment with someone else i had fun
with her this season because she was
stripped of something which
defines her
but has defined her up until now
and so i was just excited
for the opportunity that the writers had
given yennefer
we know it's dangerous but this is not
the time to be weak
it's the time to be strong something
that was created because you know it's
something we kind of go away from in the
books a little bit with jennifer's
storyline just so she can just to
enhance her character more it's not to
kind of veer away from the books so
she's not the same jennifer we're not
trying to do anything differently
but we're just trying to kind of elevate
her
kind of tell the story behind the scenes
um and i think we really got to this
season with jennifer um
yeah she finds her true sense of
self
[Music]
geralt do you know what to do with this
sorry siri sorry it was really exciting
to see siri and jennifer finally come
face to face after siri always just kind
of asking who is this uh what was it
like getting to share scenes with anya
it was so nice i mean we
know each other obviously off-screen now
before we even got being able to act
together so you know it was nice nice
having that also there's an element of
it being a bit awkward because usually
when you go on a job you kind of don't
know the person too well so you sort of
like don't really care but then we were
both a bit like well this is a bit weird
isn't it that we're now acting in front
of each other but very quickly you get
into it and then it only is useful it's
like a tool you know that trust that we
have already
so yeah it was it was a lot of fun there
were fun there were a lot of funny
moments a lot of um
obviously it's the witcher intense
moments but um yeah it was it was really
fun working with anna she's a great
singing partner i'm already clamoring
for season three i know you don't know
anything but what is one thing you would
like to see for siri in season three
well i actually do know quite a bit i i
want to see her fight a monster
yes and not just be the bait yes exactly
when you did read the season two finale
i'm curious what was your initial
reaction and what were the first
questions you had for your show writer
lauren there's a lot of original story
there obviously yeah and so it was all
about the conversations i was saying i
want to just preserve
the the truth um from
of these characters from the books and
that was my that was my my the thing i
campaigned for the most our gut is
always to stay true to the spirit of the
original books that is like our guiding
light through adaptation when i spoke to
the author really early on that's what
he asked for he said you know my books
are not the bible and no matter what i
do in the adaptation the books will
still exist so i try to make sure that
what we keep is um
sort of the the the moral and ethical
lessons of the of the books the sort of
twisted fairy tales which i love
um these amazing characters but also
this humor and the wit and the sort of
tongue in cheekness the self-awareness
in the books which i find is what really
separates them out from a lot of other
fantasy uh fantasy genre things you're
the keeper of all the secrets once fans
have finished binging season two what do
you want to tease to them about a
potential next chapter um go read the
time of contempt it is my favorite book
in the series um and
unlike a lot of the fears that i had
about adapting blood valves which was i
think very difficult
um time of contempt it lays out
beautifully for an adaptation so much
happens so much changes there are you
know just sort of uh cliffhangers left
and right a lot of deaths it's i think
it's going to be an incredible season
[Music]